[Music]
she's only 20 but Kylie the youngest
Kardashian / Jenner just became the
richest family member wealthier than
even brother-in-law Kanye her cosmetics
line has made her worth 960 million
dollars but unlike Kanye who campaigned
to get Kim on Vogue's cover or Chloe and
Kourtney's former flames who became part
of their reality shows Kylie's man
actually stays out of this moguls way
named 5 Kylie cosmetic products store no
no like products like taking a
relationship quiz and posing for GQ the
new parents together for about a year
explained how they've avoided the
dreaded so-called Kardashian curse of
failed relationships quotes we just go
the extra mile to keep our relationship
super private remember how Khloe went
public with her love for two famous
basketball stars neither of those worked
out perfectly and even though Travis is
a famous rapper he says he and Kylie
worked because quote Kylie actually
likes me for me when they first met she
wasn't even sure about him now they do
admit to fighting and clearly have a few
things to work out what are my dog's
name Norman okay
lady lady
[Music]